[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit mini
serien guten abend ihnen allen kristin
otto sie dabei mehr und hat später die
wichtigsten sportlichen meldung vor
allem fußball guten abend ja heute ein
tag der besonders in der hauptstadt böse
erinnerungen wachrief ist unser
überblick
eine tote und schwerstverletzte in
berlin nahe der gedächtniskirche fährt
ein 29 jähriger mit dem auto in eine
menschengruppe
tempo bei der windkraft die
bundesregierung will mehr fläche für
windräder festlegen und auch die regeln
für mindestabstände aufweichen
was tun im corona herbst der expertenrat
empfiehlt der politik sich frühzeitig
vorzubereiten
[Musik]
auto fährt am berliner breitscheidplatz
in menschenmenge diese alarmierende
meldung vom vormittag erinnerte viele
automatisch an die terrortat auf dem
berliner weihnachtsmarkt von 2016
entsprechend groß dann das aufgebot an
hilfs- und sicherheitskräften das
minuten später auftauchte die vorläufige
bilanz eine tote und mehrere schwerst
und schwerverletzte es war gegen 10 uhr
30 im westen berlins im stadtteil
charlottenburg
nur wenige meter entfernt vom
breitscheidplatz und der bei touristen
beliebten gedächtniskirche davor das
auto auf einem gehweg in die
menschenmenge mehr erfahren wir von
hans-jürgen viel
verwüstung und ein großaufgebot an
hilfskräften in der westlichen berliner
innenstadt sanitäter bei der
erstversorgung der zahlreichen
verletzten das tatfahrzeug steckt im
schaufenster eines ladengeschäftes an
der berliner tauentzienstraße
gegen 10 uhr 30 war der kleinwagen hier
nahe der gedächtniskirche auf dem fußweg
in eine gruppe von passanten gefahren
eine frau überlebte den aufprall nicht
mindestens zwölf menschen darunter auch
hessischer schüler auf einer
klassenfahrt wurden zum teil
lebensgefährlich verletzt bevor der pkw
das fenster einer parfümerie durchschlug
der mann ist dann eine querstraße weiter
in einem schaufenster zum stehen
gekommen also tatsächlich eingedrungen
wenn das in das gebäude durch die
schaufensterscheibe wurde dort erst mal
festgehalten von passantinnen und
passanten so mein kenntnisstand und dann
für eine einsatzkraft von uns
unmittelbar festgenommen der 29-jährige
fahrer ist mittlerweile in
polizeigewahrsam die beamten
durchsuchten bereits die wohnung des
deutsch arminias einzelne augenzeugen
berichte deuten auf eine vorsätzliche
tat aber ein richtiges bekennerschreiben
gibt es nicht es ist richtig wir werden
jetzt das auto entsprechend natürlich
untersuchen das läuft gerade der vorfall
ereignete sich nur 100 meter vom
breitscheidplatz entfernt wo der islam
ist anita briem dezember 2016 mit einem
lkw über den weihnachtsmarkt gerast war
damals starben 12 menschen mehr als 70
wurden verletzt in diesen minuten soll
in der gedächtniskirche eine
gedenkandacht stattfinden ja es ist ein
vorfall mit noch vielen offenen fragen
unfall oder vorsatz vor ort für uns ist
carsten behrendt kasten was weiß man
denn zur stunde darüber
ja wir haben eben diese
augenzeugenberichte von dem wir auch im
beitrag gerade gehört haben die sagen
der mann sei so merkwürdig hier lang
gefahren das ist nur eine vorsätzliche
tat ein vorsätzlicher eine vorsätzliche
tat gewesen sein kann die polizei aber
sagt nach wie vor sehr mit länder alle
richtungen sowohl der
verkehrsunfalldienstes jahr im einsatz
das sind ja gerade noch mal mit einer
drohne rübergeflogen haben alles
vermessen als auch die mordkommission
noch nichts bekannt ist über die
vernehmung die ersten vernehmung
ergebnisse des mannes er soll sich im
moment im krankenhaus befinden nach
zdf-informationen ist er vorbestraft
aber wir haben da noch keine konkreten
informationen und wie gesagt die
offiziellen seiten hat sich dann noch
sehr bedeckt traurige gewissheit haben
wir dass es sich bei der getöteten um
eine lehrerin aus hessen handelt die
ihre klasse bei der klassenfahrt
begleitet hat auch unter den
schwerverletzten sollen sich schüler
möglicherweise auch ein zweiter lehrer
befinden und sowohl die berliner
landesregierung als auch die hessische
landesregierung haben mittlerweile ihr
beileid und ihre anteilnahme gegenüber
den angehörigen bekundet vielen dank für
diese informationen live aus berlin
carsten behrendt war das und alles zum
tragischen tag in berlin sowie alle
neuen entwicklungen zu den hintergründen
finden sie jederzeit auch in unserer zdf
heute app
european green die mit diesem schlagwort
hat sich die eu kommission vor knapp
einem jahr deutlich mehr klimaschutz
vorgenommen heute hat das
europaparlament über die vorhaben
abgestimmt und manche dabei ausgebremst
grundsätzlich ist das erklärte ziel die
treibhaus emissionen der mitgliedsländer
sollen bis 2030 um 55 prozent gesenkt
und bis 2050 klimaneutral werden
umstrittenes herzstück der maßnahmen ist
der emissionshandel verursacher müssten
für klimaschädliche gase bezahlen
geeinigt haben sich die eu
parlamentarier auf dies den verkauf von
verbrennungsmotoren wollen sie ab 2035
verbieten tom pollock mit den details
acht gesetzespakete
1265 änderungsanträge im europäischen
parlament bestätigte sich heute das
klimaschutz eine komplexe angelegenheit
ist zum beispiel bei der reform des
emissionshandels dabei muss die
industrie für den ausstoß von
schädlichen klimagasen zahlen auch
unternehmen sollten künftig für ihre
gebäude und gewerblichen fahrzeuge zur
kasse gebeten werden doch bei der frage
wie viel co2 dabei eingespart werden
soll gab es keine einigung und am ende
schuldzuweisungen bei den grünen ist es
einfach so wir wollen die wahl gar
keinen zusätzlichen klimaschutz wenn ihr
ziel das wir für überambitioniert halten
nicht erreicht wird die cdu hat sich
hier ins bein geschossen sie dachten sie
können mit den rechten
einen deal machen und am ende werden die
grünen und die sozialdemokraten sowieso
zustimmen aber wir sind hier nicht die
steigbügelhalter den klimaschutz
abzuschleifen jetzt muss neu verhandelt
werden einigkeit herrscht beim ausstoß
von treibhausgasen von autos demnach
dürfen hersteller spätestens ab 2035
keine neuwagen mehr mit
verbrennungsmotor verkaufen stattdessen
sollen elektroautos auf dem weg in die
klimaneutrale mithelfen ein weg bei dem
für viele das leben teurer werden dürfte
ein sozialer klimafonds der eu soll
ärmere menschen unterstützen damit die
maßnahmen für sie bezahlbar bleiben und
die kosten nichts gegen die klimakrise
zu tun sind viel viel höher menschen
werden sterben menschen werden
verhungern menschen müssen sich auf die
flucht machen und deswegen müssen wir
handeln wir stellen allerdings sicher
dass wir auch in unseren gesellschaften
niemanden zurücklassen frühestens
2024 würde der klima vom kommen die
abstimmung darüber wurde heute aber
nochmal verschoben
auch die bundesregierung setzt beim
klimaschutz auf e mobilität und auf
grüne energie und will jetzt tempo
machen damit der ausbau der windenergie
deutlich schneller vorankommt plant
berlin geltende abstandsregeln für
windkraftanlagen notfalls per gesetz
aufzuheben das vorhaben ist allerdings
umstritten und ärger wahrscheinlich
vorprogrammiert britta buchholz
auch in landschaftsschutzgebieten sollen
sich künftig mehr windräder drehen
dürfen so erhöht der bund den druck auf
die länder ihre ausbauziele zu erreichen
denn zwei prozent der bundes fläche
sollen für windräder verfügbar sein
wirtschaftsminister habeck wird gerade
in jordanien für neue energieabkommen
sein appell an die bundesländer ausbauen
und zwar dringend wir haben das schlecht
genug gemacht in der vergangenheit und
deswegen war es die aufgabe meines
ministeriums dafür zu sorgen dass wir
jetzt nicht nur die förderung des eeg
vernünftig hinbekommen sondern auch eine
flächen verteilung hinbekommen der
ausbau scheitert oft an abstandsregeln
wien ein windrad an häuser gebaut werden
darf beantworten die bundesländer
unterschiedlich das gesetz fordert nun
aber erreicht ein land sein ausbauziel
nicht soll der mindestabstand wegfallen
skepsis aus sachsen
wir haben hier im freistaat sachsen
einen gesellschaftlichen frieden erzeugt
mit einer regelung 1000 meter abstand
von der wohnbebauung andere bundesländer
haben das auch und das halte ich auch
für richtig und ich finde eine
bundesregierung die weit weg ins ist in
berlin sollte sich ein stück weit auch
darauf verlassen wie die menschen vor
ort die dinge sehen die ambitionierten
ziele sind zwischen bund ländern und
ampel vorbesprochen trotzdem bedenken
auch aus der fdp
landesregierung wie in brandenburg oder
in sachsen jetzt aktuell auf 1000 meter
gesetzt wird warum soll dann der bund
warum soll robert habeck das von oben
her bestimmt kritik kommt auch vom
naturschutzbund der bestimmte vogelarten
als stärker gefährdet ansieht die
windindustrie soll allerdings für
artenschutzprogramme ausgleich bezahlen
und wir schauen jetzt in die ukraine da
bleibt der osten stark umkämpft offenbar
gelingen russische truppen dort weitere
geländegewinne das teilte der gouverneur
der region luhansk mit die stadt sehr
wie rodan jetzt die rund um die uhr
bombardiert werde müsse man womöglich
vorerst aufgeben das russische militär
sendete mit diesen bilder von
hubschrauber angriffen anzeichen ins in
und ausland sie richten sich laut moskau
gegen militärische ziele in der region
luhansk der ukrainische präsident
seelands key kündigte an dass die
ukraine in einem zitat buch der folterer
informationen über kriegsverbrechen
künftig systematisch erfassen werde
in der ukraine lagern millionen tonnen
getreide auf die viele länder in der
welt angewiesen sind ob sie exportiert
werden können darüber wurde heute in der
türkei verhandelt das problem die
ukraine saß nicht mit am tisch der
russische außenminister lavrov war zu
besuch bei seinem türkischen
amtskollegen giorgio lavrov sagte die
ukraine müsse ihre seeminen entschärfen
dann könnte das getreide mit schiffen
exportiert werden das lehnt die ukraine
ab aus angst vor russischen angriffen
der ukraine krieg auch ein schwerpunkt
auf der digital und netz konferenz re
publica in berlin im focus vor allem wie
propaganda den krieg uns das internet
aber auch den journalismus verändert von
der messe die wegen corona erstmals
wieder live stattfindet berichtet roman
leskovar rückkehr aus der pandemie
zwangspause nach drei jahren darf das
publikum zurück auf deutschlands
grösstes diskussionsforum zu online
themen auch die re publica musste das
programm wegen der ukraine krise
ergänzen die digitalisierung betreffe
längst auch unsere wahrnehmung im krieg
die frage wie kriegsberichterstattung
den heutigen zeiten funktioniert die
frage wie wir als rezipienten als
publikum mit dem informationskrieg
umgehen können ob wir mündig genug dafür
sind oder ob da noch mehr getan werden
muss das sind fragen die wir noch in den
letzten drei monaten ins programm
aufgenommen haben die
kriegsberichterstattung heute
funktioniert gleich zum auftakt thema
einer gesprächsrunde mit ukraine und
russland korrespondenten des öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunks social media werde
immer wichtiger sagt etwa die zdf
reporterin wichtiger als manch
traditionelle nachrichtenquelle ich habe
noch nie einen konflikt oder krieg
erlebt wo das internet als
informationsquelle eine so große rolle
gespielt hat wie in dieser oper ihnen
kriegen die friedrich-ebert-stiftung
musste unlängst ihr büro in moskau
schließen der leiter des russland
programms wird über die zukunft des
freien internets unter putin sprechen
für ihn drohten chinesische verhältnisse
jetzt auch in russland ich befürchte
dass menschen aktiv sind und für
freiheit im internet kempen ins ausland
gedrängt werden und ich befürchte dass
der krieg wirklich der finale vorwand
dafür ist das russische internet langsam
von dem welt internet abzukapseln neben
den vielen negativen aspekten soll genug
platz bleiben für spannendes aus der
digitalwelt gerechnet wird mit etwas
weniger teilnehmern als volk ohne alle
vorsichtigen werden einige diskussionen
auch als live-stream von zu hause aus
verfolgen können
der krieg hat die korona pandemien den
hintergrund rücken lassen aber auch weil
sich zwischenzeitlich weniger menschen
anstecken und fast alle einschränkungen
aufgehoben wurden jetzt aber warnt der
korona expertenrat der bundesregierung
wir müssen uns früh auf neue
infektionswellen den herbst und winter
vorbereiten mehr von andrea maurer
sommer in berlin viele infektionsschutz
maßnahmen sind aufgehoben corona scheint
gerade weit weg sie denken schon an
herbst und winter drängen auf
vorbereitung die mitglieder des
expertenrates der die bundesregierung
berät rechnen mit drei szenarien
haben angefangen mit einer variante in
der es deutlich günstiger läuft als in
diesem jahr also eine abgeschwächte
variante wir haben als zweites ein
basisszenario bei dem alles im
wesentlichen so bleibt wie es derzeit
ist und ein ungünstigeres szenario mit
dem auftreten einer neuen virus variante
mit stärkerer immun schlucht und
erhöhter krankheit schwere auch die iba
5 variante die aktuell auf dem vormarsch
ist haben die wissenschaftler im blick
von dem was wir wissen sind die
krankmachenden eigenschaften aber
vergleichbar mit der jetzigen variante
das heißt würde zu diesem sogenannten
basis szenario passen die expertinnen
und experten empfehlen eine neue impf
und booster kampagne sie fordern bessere
datengrundlage bessere kommunikation
einheitliche regeln von
quarantänemaßnahmen sehen sie ab wir
waren uns einig dass wir
quarantänemaßnahmen nur noch dann
empfehlen würden wenn wirklich eine
deutlich krankmachern der rehbock
auftreten würde der gesundheitsminister
erklärt heute man werde auf alle
szenarien vorbereitet sein auch
gesetzgeberisch am 23 09 läuft das
infektionsschutzgesetz aus lauterbach
will eine neufassung noch vor der
sommerpause anstoßen die fdp erst danach
uneinigkeit in der ampel
klimaschutz gerade noch ein thema bei
uns ist nötig weil der klimawandel
unerbittlich und global voranschreitet
hier sehen wir vor einigen tagen
aufgenommen was die erwärmung mit dem
größten zusammenhängenden riff dem great
barrier reef vor australiens küste macht
alles weiß ohne farbe ohne leben
korallenbleiche nennt man das weil
australien einen besonders heißen sommer
hinter sich hatte ist das wasser hier
bis zu vier grad wärmer als sonst normen
odenthal
es ist die pure pracht menschen die das
mal selbst gesehen haben schwärmen vom
great barrier reef und seinen farben
spektakel doch oft zu oft sie die
wirklichkeit so aus große teile des
riffs sind trostlos abgestorben kahl und
grau
wir hatten korallen gleichen 2016 17 20
und jetzt wieder 2022 vier massen
bleichen in denen wir auch ein
massensterben der korallen gesehen haben
ihr bestand am riff ist enorm
zurückgegangen
die ursache ist kein geheimnis das
wasser wird zu warm das ist der
klimawandel halten die mit den korallen
in symbiose leben sie ernähren und bunt
färben ertragen die wärme nicht ohne
diese algen werden die korallenbleiche
und verhungern geradezu
so eine korallenbleiche ist zwar
reparabel die tiere erholen sich wenn
der wärme stress wieder nachlässt aber
der klimawandel bringt immer kräftigere
hitzewellen längere und häufigere und
das ist das problem mit
allen mitteln versuchen sie dagegen zu
halten hier werden winzige meersalz
partikel versprüht sie sollen wolken und
durchlässiger für das sonnenlicht machen
weniger sonne weniger wärme weniger
stress fürs mehr ein begrenzter effekt
geben die wissenschaftler zu ohne eine
globale anstrengungen gegen die
erderwärmung wird das nicht reichen für
die rettung des great barrier reef
wir machen jetzt weiter mit fußball und
nations league deutschland gegen england
es gab ein unentschieden aber es war ein
richtig gutes spiel von ganz okay
immerhin gut gespielt sieg wäre besser
gewesen naja erneut 11 erneut nur ein
punktgewinn diesmal gegen england aber
dennoch lobt der bundestrainer hansi
flick die steigerung seiner mannschaft
gegenüber dem italien spiel das
potenzial ist da für die angestrebte
rückkehr in die weltspitze auch am tag
danach dreht sich bei jonas hofmann
alles um die treffsicherheit heute eine
runde golf gestern torschütze zum 1 0
und einer der besten beim beherzten
auftritts gegen die engländer die kurz
vor spielende einen es meter nach
videobeweis erhalten schlotterbeck
trifft kane und der run ins tor nur 11
aber eine gute leistung die art und
weise
wie wir fußball gespielt haben war die
für die fans für zuschauer im stadion
aber auch zu hause wahrscheinlich
einfach toll schade dass man sich
belohnt haben sie sind immer noch auf
der suche nach der ideallinie in der
nächstens league
in der bundesliga haben nun alle vereine
wieder einen trainer der fc augsburg
verpflichtet seinen wunschkandidaten
rico maßen der bisher als u23-coach bei
borussia dortmund in der dritten liga
gearbeitet hat
prozessbeginn der schweiz gegen zwei
frühere spitzenfunktionäre des fußballs
der fifa sepp blatter und der uefa
michel platini
sechs jahre haben die ermittlungen
gedauert es geht um betrug und
bestechung es drohen sogar haftstrafen
michelle platini und sepp blatter sie
waren über viele jahre die herrscher des
weltfußballs jetzt sind sie angeklagte
ich bin mir auch bewusst da sehe ich
nicht etwas
strafbar gemacht habe habe ich nicht
gemacht das sieht die schweizer justiz
anders sie wirft blatter und platini
unter anderem betrug und
urkundenfälschung vor konkret soll 2011
der damalige fifa chef blatter eine 2
millionen schweizer franken zahlung an
den damaligen uefa-chef platini
genehmigt haben warum die million
gezahlt wurden und wie die ermittler
davon erfuhren genau das soll hier in
den kommenden zwei wochen geklärt werden
und damit könnten zum ersten mal
führende ex fußball funktionäre
strafrechtlich zur verantwortung gezogen
werden denn die schweizer ermittlungen
liefen bislang wegen affären
verschleppungen pannen immer wieder ins
leere jetzt die chance der schweizer
justiz zu zeigen dass sie auch ein
strafverfahren im fussball neutral bis
zu ende führen kann heute jedenfalls hat
sepp blatter aus gesundheitlichen
gründen nicht ausgesagt morgen soll nun
beide angeklagten gehört werden sollten
sich die vorwürfe gegen sie bestätigen
drohen gefängnisstrafen von bis zu fünf
jahren
können wir ganz tiefer fall werden ja
dann war das der sport am mittwoch
finanzsystem wir haben noch die zahlen
vom mittwoch lotto und die gehen so
14 11 33 34 48 und die superzahl lautet
1 weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite 557 die
wetteraussichten für morgen eher
wechselhaft und kühl zum wochenende
sieht nach sommer aus mehr gleich von
katja schäfer wir empfehlen noch das
heute journal um 21.45 mit christian
sievers das war's einen schönen abend
für sie schön dank und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend die kaltfront von tief nana
überquert in der nacht und morgen über
tag deutschland von west nach ost dabei
gibt es vor allen dingen am alpenrand
dauerregen und der setzt schon heute
nacht ein sonst fällt auch regen aber
nicht so kräftige regen ist kann auch
mal ein gewitter dabei sein die
temperaturen sinken in dieser nacht auf
15 grad in der uckermark bis 8 grad an
der mosel und steigen morgen in
brandenburg in richtung lausitz auf 22
bis 24 grad sonst bleibt es kälter vor
allen dingen im alpenvorland da liegen
die werte bei 14 bis 16 grad denn da
bleibt es beim kräftigen dauerregen den
nun langsam nachlässt sonst wird der tag
allerdings ganz freundlich es gibt
einzelne schauer oder auch kurze
gewitter und dann wird es sommerlicher
am freitag werde noch etwas regen im
osten und danach wird es richtig heiß
mit werten bis 31 grad
und jetzt tauchen wir abfahren tag der
ozeane denn die unterwasserwelt ist in
gefahr nicht mal zehn prozent der meere
sind weltweit bislang geschützt bis 2030
sollen es 30 prozent werden auch um die
artenvielfalt zu erhalten schleppnetze
dürfen dann nur noch über schlick und
sand boden gezogen werden für die nord
und ostsee gelten die strengen regeln
ebenfalls nur so dürfen plattfische wie
die scholle und krabben weiter gefangen
werden was passiert wenn die natur aus
den tiefen des meeres zurückschlägt
erzählt 2023 der schwarm die
spektakuläre serie hier im zdf schönen
abend